>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C
>> Karen Jaffe: Good morning
>> Good morning
>> Karen Jaffe: Good morning, C.W
Ferris [phonetic] elementary school,
from Washington D.C, right?
>> Yes.
>> Karen Jaffe: Have any
of you've been here before?
Wow, great.
Welcome back, you're at the Young
Readers Center of the Library
of Congress and we're
very glad to have you.
And our partner today, this
program is Everybody Wins, D.C.,
and they have brought a
very special guest for you.
And a special guess that's in, so,
this is actually a couple,
this is really neat.
What the Young Readers Center
does with Everybody wins DC,
is bring a guest who either talks
about a career or a vocation,
or a special hobby
which is an avocation.
And today we have Doctor Jim
Salander, who's career is a surgeon
but his hobby, his
avocation is bee keeping.
How many people have
met a beekeeper before?
OK, well by the end of this morning
you're all going to meet one.
So, I'm going to turn
the program over to Jim,
he's going to talk a little
bit, show you a lot of things,
he'll do a little reading because we
always tie our programs into a book,
which you'll get to
take home with you.
So, here you go, Jim.
>> Jim Salander: Thank
you, thanks very much.
Come in a little closer because
I got stuff that's going to be --
I'm going to be passing around
and it will be easier
if everybody's up close.
There you go, that's terrific.
What's a hobby?
Who knows what a hobby is?
>> A hobby is something that
you want to do all the time.
>> Jim Salander: Something
you want to do all the time,
you get to do it all the time?
No, so when do you do it?
Do you have a hobby?
What's your hobby?
>> My hobby's playing outside.
>> Jim Salander: Playing outside?
OK, that's good.
Do you have a hobby?
What's your hobby?
>> I like to read.
>> Jim Salander: Reading, OK.
One more, one more
hobby, what's your hobby?
>> Draw pictures.
>> Jim Salander: Drawing
pictures, OK.
Good and you guys do those when?
You do those during the day?
>> After school.
>> Jim Salander: After school, yes.
And adults have hobbies too,
moms and dads and grandparents
and so forth, and I have a hobby
also, and you've already been told
that during the day I'm a doctor,
I do stuff doctoring, I do surgery,
but on the weekends,
I have a hobby too
and my hobby is keeping honeybees.
So that's what we're
going to talk about today.
How many have ever seen
a honeybee up close?
Up close. You have, OK good,
good, we'll we're going to get
to meet some of my bees here in
a few minutes [Surprise gasp]
In just a minute, just
a minute, you don't have
to worry, don't have to worry.
What are you worried about?
When I say honeybees, what
are you worried about?
>> They might sting you?
>> Jim Salander: They might sting
you, they might, they might.
But you know, there's a lot of
things out there, whether it's cars
or whether it's a knife and
fork at the dinner table,
but if you know how
to use those things
and you understand those
things, then you don't have
to worry about getting hurt.
Nobody's going to get hurt
with my bees today, OK?
You can get some good stuff from
bees, what do we get from bees?
>> Honey.
>> Jim Salander: Honey,
sure we get honey.
OK so, let's talk about
the bees and what they do
and what I do, and it will be - yes?
>> Are we going to be
able to taste some honey?
>> Taste some honey?
Well, if we're real nice to the
bees and you're not afraid of them.
>> Yay.
>> Sure, I've got some honey for
you to taste and I have some honey
for you to take home, OK?
[Applause] So, now, where do
the bees - how does this start?
Let's talk, where do the
bees get this honey from?
Where do they get it from?
Yes.
>> They get it from flowers.
>> Jim Salander: From flowers, OK.
When they go out to the flower,
when they go out to the flower,
do they get honey or do
they get something else
and then make the honey?
OK, they get something
else, what do they get?
Just a sec, just a
sec, what you say?
Well the go out and the get pollen,
we'll talk about that separate,
but what do they use
to make the honey with,
what do they use to
make the honey with?
>> Nectar.
>> Jim Salander: Nectar?
Everybody hear that word?
Nectar. Because that's what
they get from the flower, OK so,
they go out to the flower and
they collect that nectar and then,
let's see, how do they
bring that back?
If I sent you to the store -- the
nectar is like a liquid, right?
It's like milk, or it's
about that or is like water,
but how to they carry that?
They come out with a
little jug or something,
or does it come all
packaged like milk does?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: No?
How does it get there?
>> By their mouth.
>> Jim Salander: By their mouth?
So, they just fill
up their mouth hole?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: No?
Then how to they do that?
How do the bees -- yes?
>> They swallow it and then
they go all the way to the --
>> Jim Salander: What?
They swallow it?
But how do they get it?
How do they get it in?
I have a picture of
some bees here --
well did we decide how they do that?
>> Through their nose.
>> Jim Salander: Through their nose?
Like an elephant?
>> No, the antennas.
>> Jim Salander: No,
the antennas are --
we're going to talk about those in
a little bit, those are up here.
>> Their tongues
>> Jim Salander: Their tongues, they
have a long tongue, a longue tongue;
I'll show you a picture of it.
Here's the tongues -- I only
have this to pass around, sure,
but here's some bees, they're in a
hive and they got their tongues out
and they're doing stuff with the
honey here so, I'm just going
to show you what their
tongues look like.
>> Jim Salander: OK, see the tongue?
A thick long like,
you guys got tongues?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: Let's see
your tongues, the tongues.
Now, imagine, imagine you went
to the store with someone --
>> Jim Salander: Yes, I'm sorry.
Imagine if you went to the store
to pick up a quarter of milk.
You go there with your mother,
your grandmother, your brother,
your sister o you go
yourself, and you need to pick
up that quarter milk, so,
you're going to do what?
You're going to go to the
store; you're going to pick
up a quarter milk, right?
Pick it up with your
hands and carry it home.
But the bees aren't going to do
that, they're going to pick it
up with their tongue,
and they're going to go,
just like these guys here.
That's a pretty tough trick, and
then they're going to swallow it
and then bring it back to the hive.
Well, how to they get it up?
The bees do something
that, if you did it,
it would be because you were
sick, but the bees swallow it,
and they put it in a special
stomach and then when they get back
to the hive, they bring it up.
OK? Wait a minute, just a minute,
how many of you guys drink milk?
How many of you drink milk?
Well, the cows eat grass and
stuff and the milk comes out,
you drink the milk [Grossed out
expression] How many eat eggs?
So, we get a lot of different
stuff from animals, and the animals
or the insects kind of do
things differently than you
and I would do if we
were making food.
Now, what else do they get
at the hive that they may --
at the flower to bring back home?
Somebody else talked
about it a minute ago.
>> Pollen?
>> Jim Salander: Pollen?
What's pollen?
What's the pollen, who
hasn't answered something?
>> Pollen is something in, like they
got that stuff that I get of honey,
there was, you know, honey things.
>> Jim Salander: It's not little
honey things, it's different
than the nectar, is
different, what is it?
>> Pollen is, when they get close to
a flower, pollen it's on the flower
and it makes you sneeze
and helps the flowers grow.
>> Jim Salander: Right,
that's what the --
the flower has the
nectar inside the flower
and then it also has this
pollen, but what is pollen?
If I gave it to you,
what would it look like?
What would it look like?
>> Jim Salander: What
does pollen look like?
Is it liquid, like the nectar?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: Is it like
a cube of sugar, a big chunk?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: What's
it look like?
>> It looks like a small crumb?
>> Jim Salander: Like a small what?
>> Crumb.
>> Jim Salander: Yes,
it's like small crumb,
it's like salt or pepper.
It's little, little,
little bits and pieces, OK?
And the bees do two
things with the pollen, OK?
One thing is they pack up some of
that pollen and they take it back
to the hive, and I'm going
to show you that in a minute.
I'm going to show you what that
looks like when the bees get it back
to the -- back home, but
what else do they do with it?
What else happens when
they go to the flower?
And this is a real important part,
because this is what the
flower gets out of the deal.
I mean, what's the flower doing, why
is the flowers giving them nectar?
>> When they get the nectar,
the seeds from the flower fall
and they make other flowers.
>> Jim Salander: Well the
seeds, not seeds but the pollen,
we're talking about the pollen.
When they go to get the nectar,
they come over here to the flower
and they're drinking it up, OK?
We will hear [slurping sound],
and what happens is they get
that pollen all over
themselves, it's like if you were
at the table eating and you
had a -- you got kind of messy,
you get the food all over yourself,
or you might get something else all
over yourself, and what they
do is they go to one flower
and then they go to another
flower, and that pollen that gets
on them gets spread
to another flower.
And that's very important
for the flower part of this,
and that's what the flower
gets out of this deal,
that's a very important job that
the bee has, to spread that pollen
around so that the flowers --
so the flowers can do what?
>> Grow.
>> Jim Salander: Grow, and what
happens when the flowers grow
after the bees have been there?
What do we get from those
flowers, just pretty flowers?
>> No, honey.
>> Jim Salander: What happens?
What becomes of that flower?
>> They bloom
>> Jim Salander: They bloom,
OK and then what happens,
what happens to that flower?
This is important.
>> It grows.
>> Jim Salander: It grows into what?
>> A bigger, a bigger flower.
>> Jim Salander: A
bigger flower, yes.
What else happens?
>> A tree.
>> Jim Salander: A tree, and
what do we get from the trees?
>> Apples.
>> Jim Salander: Everybody
hear that?
Stand up. What do we get from that
tree that the bee gives the pollen
to the flowers, and the flower gets
bigger, and the tree gets bigger,
and then what do we
get from the flower?
>> Apples.
>> Jim Salander: Everybody
hear that?
Apples and pears, and
all kinds of other --
pumpkins [crosstalk]
pumpkins don't grow on trees,
you're absolutely right,
you can sit down, thank you.
But there's a whole lot of food that
you guys eat, and that you guys see
on the table that the
bees are part of that,
that's what the bees are doing.
But we're here to talk, not so
much about the apples or the pears
or the pumpkins, or the
squash, or the almonds.
Almonds, how many eat nuts?
How many like nuts?
Almonds, walnuts, big
deal with the bees.
But let's talk about the honey.
The bees have gone out there;
let's see this might be a good time
to meet some of the bees.
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: You
want to do that?
Let's -- OK, now let
me just grab you,
before everybody gets all concerned
here, these are not living,
they are not living, they have spent
the last few weeks in the freezer
of my house, they're going
to stay in the plastic bag,
you will not get stung, OK?
Now, we're going to pass them out
and I want you to look at them,
we're going to take a couple of
minutes to look at them real close,
and I want to see -- please,
they're in a plastic bag.
But I want you to look at
different parts of them,
some of you may have two bees in
there, I want you to see the wings,
I want you to see the antenna.
They're all going to get passed
out -- let me get some more.
Here, there's enough for everybody,
there's enough for everybody.
[Crosstalk] If you don't want it you
don't have to but I can promise you,
nobody is going to get
hurt with these bees today.
>> You want to know
what I know about bees?
They taste with their feet.
>> Jim Salander: They
taste with their --
we can talk about that
-- with their antenna?
Has everybody got at least one?
What I want to show you --
[crosstalk] OK, can
you see, can you see?
First, I want you to see --
first of all, how small they are,
these are just little
things, the little guys, OK?
They're little tiny things and
now I want you to see their wings
that they use to fly around with
and to bring back the nectar
and to bring back the pollen.
Now, some of you will be
able to see on the head,
those two little things of the top?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: What
are those called?
>> Antennas.
>> Jim Salander: The antennas
and those are very important
because that's what -- just like
you, if you were in a dark room,
and I handed you something, how
would you know what I gave you?
Your hands, right?
And that's basically what the
bees do with their antenna,
is they use their hands,
not to pick up,
but they use their
antenna to feel things.
Some of you will also see
in your bees, if you look --
you can see the head and
you can see the eyes,
now here's the important part, guys.
I want you to look at the other end
of the bee, the other end of the bee
up close; some of you may
see the bee's stinger.
>> I see it
>> Jim Salander: You may see
that little pointed thing
at the end of its butt.
>> Ugh.
>> Jim Salander: That's
what he's got,
it's not a tail there,
it's his stinger.
Can you see him?
You don't see, you may
not have a stinger,
you may not see the stinger.
What do you got?
A couple of guys in
there, a couple of gals.
Sure, you do, see that little
pointy thing right there?
[Crosstalk].
What did you ask?
>> Are these girls?
>> Jim Salander: These are
girls, they're all girls.
Yes, you see?
The stinger's right there.
Kids, these are all girl bees.
[Shouting] These are all girl bees.
>> How can you tell them apart?
>> Jim Salander: Well,
more importantly,
the bees can tell them apart.
But I know that these are girls,
I'll tell you that in a minute,
I'll explain to everybody.
OK everybody, you got
to know your bees,
let's take them back up,
we'll take them back up.
>> Well, you got a dandy
here, this is great --
did everybody see the wings?
Everybody see the antlers,
or the antennas?
The antlers.
[Crosstalk].
Now, somebody asked me --
I'm sorry, what's your name?
>> Jolane [phonetic].
>> Jim Salander: Joy?
>> Jolane.
>> Jim Salander: Jolane.
You asked me, who asked me if
I knew they we're girl bees?
There are three kinds of bees
in a hive, three kinds of bees.
What kind of bees are there?
Queen bee.
>> Boy bees.
>> Jim Salander: Boy
bees that they're called?
Drones and then there's the lady
bees which are the worker bees
that you have, and
here's some other bees,
just to show you these are
all kind of old and dried up,
but what I want you to see here --
what I want you to see
is the different size,
this top bees here are queen
bees, they're all kind of dried
up so you can't see very much of --
but these are the size of the
boy bees, they're the drones
and the girl bees are on the
bottom, they're smaller, OK?
OK, everybody see these back here?
These are the boy bees and these are
the girl bees, this one's broken,
these are the boy bees,
these are the queen bees.
>> Do these have pins in them?
>> Jim Salander: Yes, they're pins.
Yes, coming over there.
Excuse me, excuse me, excuse me,
here are the boy bees,
they're the bigger bees.
And these are the girl
bees, this one's broken.
And this is the queen bee.
>> And what's that?
>> Jim Salander: Excellent question.
>> Who's that one?
>> Jim Salander: OK, now
when I pass these kids --
up, just a sec, just a sec.
Somebody asked me over
here about why these bees
on the top the queen bees, had
a little piece of paint on them,
they have a little
green dot on them.
And the reason for that
is that in the hive --
a hive is where they live,
that's their home right?
In the hive, there are all these
bees, there's thousands of bees,
thousands of bees in there, and
if I want to go and see the queen,
to be sure that she's healthy,
or if I want to do something
with the queen, it's very, very
difficult to find them because,
as you can see there's
not much difference.
And so, then you can mark
them with a little tiny dot
from a magic marker,
a little bit of paint,
and that's what this little one
right there is -- OK, I'm sorry.
Those are the queen bees up here.
OK, so the bees collect up the
nectar, they collect up the pollen,
how do they bring the
pollen back to the hive?
How do they bring it
back to the hive?
They swallow the nectar --
>> And they put it in a special
stomach, and then when they get back
to the hive they bring it back.
>> Jim Salander: That's the
nectar, how about the pollen?
That stuff that's like
pep - they what?
[crosstalk]Well, no, their body is
for sharing with the other flowers,
they carry it in like a
little saddle, like a pocket,
just like if you had
something you wanted to carry,
they have little pockets on
their sides and a carrier, OK?
Like little saddle
bags on a bicycle.
OK, so they come back
to the hive, right?
And these -- I got hives here,
there are no living bees in here,
there are no live bees,
but this is the hive,
and what the hive is,
is a stack of boxes, OK?
And there's a top,
and there's a bottom.
Now, when you go home at night,
you just kind of throw your stuff
in the house, or you
have - are there closets?
And where do you keep books,
where do you keep books?
>> On the shelves
>> Jim Salander: On shelves, and
where do you keep your clothes?
>> In my closet
>> Jim Salander: OK, you
got a place to put that.
Well, when the hive's -- when the
bees come back to their house,
they have to have places
to put their stuff, right?
And so, my job is to give them
the box and inside the box I got -
the shelves, I give
them piece of wood, OK?
>> What's the wood for?
>> Jim Salander: Them I give
them a piece of plastic,
and I put the two together,
I put the two together,
and this is what it looks like.
>> That's a honeycomb.
>> Jim Salander: It' still not
honeycomb, because now if they put
in on there, it would
kind of smush off, right?
That wouldn't work very well.
It'd be like having a dresser
and no drawers in it, or a drawer
and no bottom on the
-- you put it on
and the clothes falls on the bottom.
So, look what the bees
do, look what the bees do.
The bees have the wax, where
do the bees get the wax from?
[crosstalk] Kids, let's have
a hand, let's have a hand,
where do the bees get the wax from?
Just a sec.
>> The flowers?
>> Jim Salander: No, they
don't get it from the flowers;
they don't get it from the flowers.
Who has not answered?
Yes?
>> Pollen?
>> Jim Salander: No, they don't
get it from the pollen either,
where do they get the wax from,
where do they get the wax?
>> The nectar?
>> Jim Salander: No, no.
Let me tell you where
the wax comes from,
because they get a lot
of it, look at this.
There's wax, there's more wax,
there's all these spaces and look
at this, and this is
- what is the matter?
This is the pollen,
this is the pollen.
Look, there's a bee.
Kids, kids, kids, kids, kids.
So, what do they put in the spaces?
In here, they put honey,
what else goes in there?
>> Wax?
>> Jim Salander: I'm sorry?
>> Jim Salander: No.
>> Pollen?
>> Jim Salander: What else
do they put in their closet?
I showed you here, I showed you
that they put in the pollen,
what else do they have in
there, besides pollen and honey?
Wait a minute, wait a minute, wait a
minute kids, we got all these bees,
where do the bees come from?
Oh. And where do they -- what?
Where do they come from?
>> The queen.
>> Jim Salander: They come from the
queen and the queen lays an egg,
well, where do they put the egg?
[crosstalk] Wait a minute, wait
a minute, kids, one at a time.
Where do they put -- the queen's got
all these thousands of bees there,
we can't just dump them in a
drawer and let them all fall
into the bottom, where does
the queen put the eggs,
so the eggs will go up and be bees?
Now, think about that.
>> They have them in the
honey, in the honeycomb.
>> Jim Salander: Well, yes but
they don't mix them in together,
but what she does is they have a --
they put them in the
same kind of arrangement,
now this is a little
discolored, this is darker,
because it's been used many
times as a nursery, for the bees.
Here's a nursery that hasn't
been used very much, OK?
This has been used a lot and that's
why it's dark and she goes in there,
and the puts in an egg
in each one of these
and then the worker bees come
along, give it a bit drop of honey,
and somebody else gives them
a little drop of the pollen,
and then they close it over.
And then the egg becomes a bee, and
then the bee climbs out and goes
to work with everybody else.
But let's look at this for a second;
oh, I didn't answer the question
where the wax comes from.
Where does the wax come from?
One more person gets the try.
>> The wax comes from the honey.
>> Jim Salander: No, the wax
doesn't come from the honey,
when you go out in the
yard, when you go outside
and play real hard, do you sweat?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: So, little
drops of water come off, right?
Listen to this one guys,
the bees sweat wax.
Now, they don't do it all them,
they don't work and run around
and it just comes dripping off
of them but if they need wax,
if they need wax to fill this
up, some of them begin --
the wax coming off them and they
take and mold it, into this,
and they mold it into this,
and that's where it comes from
and that's also where
they put the honey.
That's honey, that's the honey.
It's gross?
>> It's not gross, it's awkward.
>> You say it's gross?
Too close?
You guys are going to get real
close to the honey, is anybody going
to eat the honey I give you?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: How
much closer can you get?
Here we go, there's -- now look
at this, it doesn't come off.
Because, because the bees have
put little tops on their jars,
a little top's on here and this is
capped honey, they've capped it,
so that it can store there,
and why do the bees have all
this honey in the hive anyway?
Why do they make honey?
>> So they can drink
some food an eat food?
>> Jim Salander: That's
right, so they can eat it,
because in the winter
now, there's no flowers --
well, there's a few flowers
out now but in January,
when they get hungry, they
can't go to the store,
they can't go to the grocery store,
they can't go to "Whole Foods"
or the Stayflay [phonetic].
They can't go to the vending machine
and put some money in and get
out a candy bar, they eat the
honey so they have to make --
and my job is to trick them
into making more honey.
Well, let's go back to this one
for just a second, on the subject
of the nursery where the bees
were, you see the color, it's dark,
it's much darker than
the other one, right?
OK, and here's a funny hole in it
for some reason, I'm not sure why.
What else do you see here, what
do you see here that's different,
tell me, somebody tell me something.
What do you see here
that's different?
>> It's darker and they got --
>> Jim Salander: Well, first of
all it's a little irregular, right?
This one was nice and
smooth, see this is smooth
and this is kind of bumpy.
Besides being bumpy, does
anybody see anything different?
What's different here?
Big holes, you mean these guys here?
Yes, they're big holes, OK.
Everybody get your thinking cap on.
Why are some of the holes
bigger than the other holes?
>> Because they put
too much wax in there.
>> Jim Salander: Why
do the bees go ahead
and make some bigger than others?
Who can answer that question for me?
Who can answer -- who has not
answered a question before?
>> I have answered a question?
>> Jim Salander: You
have answered a question;
well can you answer this one?
Why are they bigger, who can tell
me why these holes are bigger?
Yes.
>> They're bigger because,
the holes are big
because probably some
bees need to come out.
>> Jim Salander: Well, the bees
can come out, the bees can come
out of the small ones too, but why
would the bees go to the trouble
of making big holes and small holes?
>> The queen lays eggs
inside of the thing.
>> Jim Salander: OK,
yes, she put eggs in,
I'm going to give you a
hint, here comes the hint,
everybody ready for a hint?
[Crosstalk] Some of the eggs might
be bigger, the eggs aren't bigger,
but why do you need a bigger hole?
>> Because there might
be a lot of boy bees --
>> Jim Salander: That's the answer,
because the boy bees
need a bigger space,
because they come out bigger bees.
>> But there aren't that many.
>> Jim Salander: You're
right, there aren't that many,
there aren't that many, and
overall in the hive, they only make
up a very small percentage of
the eggs that the queen lays.
But she comes around; now listen
to this, you got to believe me,
you got to have faith in this.
The queen comes around and she
comes to one of those little holes,
or big holes, and she
feels with her antenna, OK?
And she says, "Oh, this is a small
hole", and in there she lays an egg
that will become a
female, and if she comes
around to a hole that's
big, what happens?
She lays an egg that
going to become a boy.
Now there's the trick for you.
OK, then she does that and the
worker bees make the holes --
make the spaces, based on what
they think are going to need,
it's like if you were building
a house at home and you said,
"Well I need a dresser, I need a
closet, that's got this much space
in it, because I'm going to
have a lot of dresses and coats,
or maybe I'll only
make one this size
because my coats are
going to be smaller".
So, now we know about the wax,
we know about the baby bees,
we know about the honey
[surprise gasp] They are not --
didn't I tell you at the beginning
that nobody was going
to get stung or hurt?
>> They're frozen
>> You put them in a freezer?
>> Jim Salander: I went
to hive earlier this year
and the whole hive had
died, the bees had died, OK?
And so, I took it back to the
house and I saved it, so that one,
that I could show it to you guys
and two, I'm going to give it
to some other bees in the spring,
but on one of these frames
[crosstalk] These are the bees
that clustered around here, OK, and
this is what they happen to be --
they died in place, and so I
brought these in to show it
to you, what the bees look like.
Because the bees cluster in a group
in the winter, they don't hibernate
like bears and they don't
migrate like -- who migrates?
What animal migrates and
goes away for the winter
where it's warn, who does that?
>> A bear?
>> Jim Salander: No,
the bears go to sleep.
They hibernate in a cave or some
dark place, but who goes away
for the winter where it's warm?
>> Birds?
>> Jim Salander: Birds,
that's called...
>> Hibernate.
>> Jim Salander: No, sleeping is
the hibernating, flying away is the
>> Migrating.
>> Jim Salander: Migrating.
Well, the bees don't do either,
the bees don't do either.
If I turn the temperature
in this room down,
so that 'it was real cold,
until there was snowing in here,
that's how cold it was,
what would you guys do?
If you couldn't leave?
>> I would put my coat on.
>> Jim Salander: You might
snuggle up with each other,
when you come out from
playing outside on a cold day;
doesn't it feel good when somebody
gives you a hug, kind of feels warm?
And that's what the
bees do in the winter;
they snuggle up to keep warm.
OK so, we got the bees, we got
the honey, and we got the hive.
Now, let me tell you what my job is,
how I get the honey out of the hive,
once I've tricked the bees
into making more honey
than they need, OK.
A hive is a stack of boxes, yes?
How much honey do you
think the bees need
for the winter, in
one stack of boxes?
And I'll tell you that they
don't go next door to borrow any,
and they don't go to
the 7-Eleven to buy any.
So, we have a stack of
boxes that's a hive,
how much honey do you think
they need for the winter?
I need pounds, somebody tell
me the number of pounds.
>> 300 pounds?
>> Jim Salander: 300 pounds,
not that much, not that much.
>> 100 -- 200 pounds.
>> Jim Salander: No,
they only need 60 pounds.
>> What?
>> Jim Salander: But we're going to
taste some honey in a little while,
from this jars that
are a half a pound.
And as long as I have this out
here, these are three jars of honey,
three jars of honey,
now this jar is bigger,
but what else is different
about these three jars?
Look at them, and tell me what's
different about these three jars.
>> One is light and one is --
>> Jim Salander: This
looks real dark, right?
How about these two?
This honey here was from
2004, that was 11 years ago -
was that before you guys were born?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: So, this jar
of honey is older than you guys.
But what's the difference
between these two jars
of honey besides the age?
Is the difference in color, right?
>> Yes.
>> Jim Salander: Why
is a different color?
Why is this honey so, so dark?
>> Because it's older.
>> Jim Salander: No, this honey's
just a year old, it's not that old.
But why are two jars of
honey different color?
Different color.
>> Are those made by
different kinds of bees?
>> Jim Salander: Different
kinds of bees, no,
they all make the same stuff.
>> Oh.
>> Jim Salander: They
all make the same stuff.
Yes. Different what?
Different kinds of honey, but how
does it get to be different kinds?
These are from the same
place, different years.
Same place, different years.
One more - oh, one more, one more.
Excuse me, everybody be very quiet.
What's the answer?
>> Do they get it from
different flowers?
>> Jim Salander: Different flowers,
different flowers, excellent answer.
This year they went to
all these flowers here,
this year maybe it was raining
one day and they couldn't get
to these flowers over here, so they
went for those flowers over there,
and they came up with
different colors,
and it tastes a little different.
And what do you think happened here?
They were really different flowers
in that area where those bees were,
this was called buckwheat honey.
>> Buckwheat honey?
>> Jim Salander: And it's almost
like molasses, it's very dark,
but it's just honey, no
chemicals, no nothing.
So, how do I get in and out of the
hive without getting you-know-what?
Stung, how does that happen?
I don't put them all in the
freezer the night before.
>> You use a special suit?
>> Jim Salander: A
special suit, come on up.
I need some people to try on
the equipment and to hold -
just a second, and to hold
some of the tools that I use,
but you got to be quiet so
you can hear the whole story.
Once you come on, you
come on up first,
and then we'll take a
family picture, there we go.
OK, all set, you can put
your arms out on there,
I need a couple more
people, where is it --
right here, right here come on up.
Over the top, there
you go, there we go.
I got somebody else come on up.
Here we go, where's my other --
here we go, I'm sorry I stepped
on your toe, put that on,
just like a jacket, and
I got one more that's got
to come, who's going to -- ?
>> Me, me, me.
>> Jim Salander: Right there,
you come on up, the flower girl.
Now, I got some other stuff that I
need help with, I need other stuff,
because I want to show
you some other tools.
There you go.
I want to show you some other tools.
Now look at this item.
>> What is the smoke thing?
>> Jim Salander: Just a second,
this keeps the bees off of my face
and off my clothing and off
my -- and then I have this,
I have this, what is this?
>> A filter?
>> Jim Salander: It's a smoker.
Now watch, I want to
show you something.
Uh, uh, what's your name?
>> Shelissa [phonetic].
>> What is it?
Shelly?
>> Shelissa.
>> Jim Salander: Shelissa,
so when I come
over to Shelissa, she
doesn't like it.
And he doesn't like it either.
Now wait a minute, the
bees don't like it either.
And so, if I come into the
hive and I give it a puff --
what I do is dug a little fire
in here [surprise gasp] I
dug a little fire in there,
and out comes smoke, there's no fire
in there now, and the bees don't
like it either, they move away.
And so, that's what happens, I use
this smoker to blow a little smoke
on the bees, it doesn't hurt them,
it's not hot, it's not fire, OK?
So, I need somebody
to hold this for me.
>> Me.
>> Jim Salander: OK, I
have this, I have a brush -
come on up, the front of the brush.
I have special tools --
where's my other special,
oh here it is right there.
Special tools for going in,
and look what this tool does.
>> Is it a scraper?
>> Jim Salander: No,
this is not scrapers.
Watch this.
If there are two of these that
are real close together, this --
this tool, see this hook over there?
It goes there and it
allows me to pick that up.
So, I need some people
to hold these.
>> Me.
>> Jim Salander: There
we go, just one second,
and when I bring all
those back to the hive --
let's have some other
people hold these.
You can --
>> Am I holding this right?
>> Jim Salander: Will you hold that?
Who wants to hold the honey?
>> Me, me [crosstalk].
>> Jim Salander: Well,
here's something,
here's something that's very
interesting, look at this,
look at this, wait a minute,
you don't know what it is.
What else do you think the bees
don't like besides the smoke?
>> Water.
>> Vitamins.
>> It's water.
>> Water.
>> Jim Salander: It's just water.
>> Just like kids.
>> Jim Salander: Here
we got the bees;
somebody's got to hold the bees.
OK, we need a group
picture, everybody else stand
up over this way here, so
we can have a group picture,
we got to have somebody
hold the honey.
>> Me, me.
>> Jim Salander: Hold it, hold it.
I need some holders for
these, no, no you got that on.
Here you go.
Who else who's got
something to hold?
[Crosstalk] Who wants to hold
the one with the bees on it?
OK, just hold it up over your head.
You got it?
Hold it up, you got it?
Everybody got something?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: You
want to hold this one?
Hold it up, turn around, turn
around, hold it up, hold it up.
OK, here we go, OK guys, then
there, turn towards the camera.
Well, you got to hold this.
Hold this over your head so
they can see that, here we go.
OK guys; let's have
everything back, slowly,
slowly [crosstalk]There you go.
Did you get to stick
the finger in there?
Quick, quick, quick, stick a finger.
You see this, you see these guys
here, see, these were the male bees,
the boy bees were down there.
See that, and these are girl
-- the girl bees are up here.
You see that, look at this.
This are the boy bees here,
these are the boy bees
down there[crosstalk] A couple more
questions, a couple more questions.
Now, what else -- we talk about
what the bees do with the wax.
What can we -and we know
what they do with the honey,
what do we do with the wax?
What do we do with the wax,
what can you do with the wax?
>> Make candles?
>> Jim Salander: Make candles.
So, what I do, is I collect some
of this wax, and I melt it down,
and I strain it, and then I pour
into this, and out comes that,
a candle that you can light.
What's this thing in the
middle called, by the way?
What's this string here
in the middle called?
>> A tweet.
>> Jim Salander: A tweet?
No.
>> A twig?
>> Jim Salander: A what?
A twig? No.
>> A thread?
>> Jim Salander: I'm going
to give you a new word
then, it's a new word.
>> Match.
>> Jim Salander: No, match
is what you light it with.
What's in the middle
is called a wick, wick.
>> I was close.
>> Jim Salander: W-I-C-K,
that's a wick.
So, you can make candles from it,
because a long time ago
there weren't electricity.
Well, now we got something else
that's very important to go through,
now that we're on the subject
of light and electricity.
So, we've got a stack,
and I'll do one more thing
and then we're going to read.
We have a stack of boxes, OK?
Does anybody see any
windows here in this box?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: Does anybody
see any electric light bulbs
in this box?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: Now, wait a minute.
So, we have a bunch of boxes,
maybe six or eight of them,
with no windows and
no electric lights.
Oh-oh. There's a door at the bottom?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: There's a door
at the top, a little opening
for them to come in and out of.
But once they come back
to the hive, how does --
if you went to the store,
you were on a walk one day,
and you found a place that
were giving away free candy,
and you wanted to come
back and tell your friends
about it, how would you do that?
You'd come back and --
>> Walk.
>> Jim Salander: You'd walk back
and you tell them about the candy?
You'd say, "Hey, there's candy over
there, in fact I brought you a piece
of it, here's a piece
of it, let's all go,
it's just down the street", right?
But it's dark in there.
When you were looking at the bees,
did you see ears on those bees?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: No ears.
No ears and their mouth
doesn't talk, how are they going
to tell the other bees
where the flowers are?
Antennas? Not too much,
not too much.
Well, I'm going to tell you exactly
what the secret of the bees is,
how they talk to each
other in this circumstance.
They -- they dance.
Everybody on your feet,
everybody on your feet.
I'm going to teach
you the bee dance.
OK, but you got to
listen; you got to listen.
First of all, what they
do is they go in a circle,
they dance in a circle and depending
upon - it's like a little figure
of eight, and that's how it
tells them the direction.
>> Jim Salander: OK, stop.
Now we got direction to how
to get to the candy store,
but we don't know how
far the candy store is,
so what do you think they do?
They jiggle their behinds.
That's how they do it, so everybody
give their behinds a jiggle,
everybody give your
behinds a jiggle.
OK, stop, stop, stop.
Now I want you to do them both of
them together, I want you to walk
in a little bit of a circle, and
I want you jiggle your bottom,
OK, very good, very good.
Now that was the easy
part, but if you were a bee
and it depended upon -- because what
you're doing is you're getting honey
for everybody else.
It's not just for you that
you're getting the honey;
they got to cooperate with all the
other bees to go out and get all
that nectar, and bring it back so
that those bees can have something
to eat, and the bees this winter
can have something to eat,
so they got to cooperate.
So, it's very important for
this last step in the bee dance,
and it's the hardest step.
Close your eyes, because it's
dark in there, it's dark, so,
I want everybody to
close their eyes,
walk in a circle and
wiggle your behind.
And that's the bee dance,
that's the bee dance.
OK guys that's it.
So, listen, what you
have to understand,
everybody had a good
time, jiggling --
for the bees, it's
a serious business.
Everybody have a seat,
everybody have a seat.
What I want to do is, how many
know this book "Winnie the Pooh"?
Now, when you leave here today,
when you leave here today
everybody will have a book about
"Winnie the Pooh", and
I'm going to read you --
Pooh is a bear, if you don't
know the book, Pooh is this bear
in the middle, he's Pooh Bear,
and Winnie is his friend,
and I want to read
a little bit to you
about Pooh Bear who
lives in the woods.
"One day when he was out walking" --
that's Pooh, here's his picture
there, "he came to an open space
in the middle of a
forest, and in the middle
of the place there was a large oak
tree and from the top of the tree,
way at the top of the tree,
there came a loud buzzing noise."
Can everybody make a buzzing noise?
Excellent.
"Winnie the Pooh sat down on the
foot of the tree and put his head
between his paws and
began to think".
OK, everybody put their
head between their paws,
and think, OK come back again.
Here he is right here.
"First of all", he said to
himself the buzzing noise
like that means something.
Everything means something, right?
You don't get a buzzing noise
like that just buzzing buzzing
without it meaning something.
If there's a buzzing noise,
somebody's making the buzzing noise,
and the only reason for
making a buzzing noise
that I know of, is
because you are a --
>> Bee.
>> Jim Salander: So, here he is,
he is looking up and
he sees these bees.
And then he thought
another long time".
What do you think he's
thinking about?
Yes, he's thinking about honey.
"And he said, 'and the
only reason for being a bee
that I know of is making honey'.
And then he got up, 'and the
only reason for making honey is
so that I can eat it',
this is Pooh speaking.
"So, he began to climb the tree",
and here he is climbing this tree,
see he's all the way up here, and
look what they did with the words,
they put the words up on the side
like they were climbing,
the words here.
Is that fun?
"He climbed, and he
climbed, and he climbed,
and as he climbed he sang
a little song, to himself,
and it went like this", I taught
you the bee dance, now we're going
to learn the bear's song.
"'Isn't it funny how
a bear likes honey?
Buzz, buzz, buzz, I
wonder why he does'.
Then he climbed a little
further and a little further,
and a little further
and by the time" --
that way he had another
song, so he's climbing
up the tree, see him climbing here?
And he's going up and up and up,
trying to get to the
bees right here on top.
"'It's very funny' -- this is his
song, 'it's very funny thought
that if bears were bees, and they
built their nests at the bottom
of trees, and that being so, if the
bees were bears, we shouldn't have
to climb up these stairs'.
He was getting rather tired by
this time, so that's why he began
to sing a complaining song.
He was nearly there and just
as he stood on the top branch,
the top branch to get
the hive, crack.
Oh, oh, oh helps Pooh as he dropped
ten feet on the branch below,
"'if only I hadn't -- he
said as he bounced 20 feet
to the next branch -- you
see what I meant to do?'
He explained as he turned
head over heels and crashed
on another branch 30 feet below,
'that's what I meant to do'.
Of course, it was rather -- he
admitted as he slithers very quickly
to the next branches, 'it
all comes I suppose' --
he decided as he said
goodbye to the last branch.
And he spun around three times
and flew gracefully into a bush,
it all comes because -why
did this happened to Pooh?
>> Because he was climbing the tree.
>> Jim Salander: But why
was he climbing the tree?
>> To get the honey
>> Jim Salander: "'It all comes from
liking honey so much, oh help'".
Well, we have some honey for
you guys today to taste here,
and then you have some honey that
your teacher is going to give you
at school at the end of the day
that you can take home and share it
with somebody else if you like.
We're going to have it on a spoon
and we're going to eat some honey
from last year, and then these
are the little packages here,
let me just show you
what this looks like.
These are packages of honey
sticks; you guys know honey sticks?
>> No.
>> Jim Salander: No?
Well OK, what it is it's a little
plastic tube, a little plastic tube
and it's filled with honey.
And when you go home, not at
school, not on the way home,
but when you get home, you can
either bite off the end of this,
just a little bit of a nip, or you
can have somebody else help you
with scissors and make a
little hole there at the end,
and then you can suck
the honey out, OK?
There's enough here
for each one of you,
and for the teachers as well, OK?
We got time for a couple
of questions,
anybody got more questions?
Yes?
>> How come can't we
get a jar of honey?
>> Jim Salander: A
jar of honey, well --
I'll tell you, if you
keep these someday,
you can have many jars of honey.
Well, maybe when you
get to be big you can,
maybe when you get to be big.
You know that the President
has bees at the White House?
They're at the White House.
Now he doesn't go out to do it
himself, and his wife doesn't
but there's a man there that
keeps the bees at the White House.
What other questions do you have?
Yes.
>> Where do the eggs come from?
>> Jim Salander: The
eggs come from the queen,
the queen lives for
three or four years.
The female worker bees only live
for about four or five weeks, so,
she is busy laying
eggs all of the time,
and in a hive that's really
working hard, in June and July,
before I steal all the honey, there
maybe 60 or 80,000 bees in there,
as many people to show up in a
Red Skins game, all in one hive,
all working together,
cooperating and getting that done
so that they will have honey
and so that I'll have honey
and so that you'll have honey.
>> Where does the queen come from?
>> Jim Salander: Where does what?
>> Jim Salander: I'm sorry,
where does the queen come from?
The queens -- if the hive is doing
poorly, if the queen gets sick,
if the queen gets old, if the queen
dies, then the other bees will try
and take one of the eggs that she
has laid and make it into a queen,
they get the queen before
she dies, hopefully,
to lay an egg in a
special large hole,
even larger than the ones
that I showed you, OK?
Much bigger, they're about
the size of my little finger,
and she puts a female egg in there
and then they put some extra stuff
in there, and she develops
as a queen,
and she can live four, five years.
I don' do it that way,
but there are people
that keep bees who raise queens.
Hundreds of them and they
come in little boxes,
they come in little boxes with a
little screen and a little plug
of sugar at the end, and
you put it in the hive,
and the other bees will eat out
that sugar and let her release
into the hive, so that she can
become the queen of that hive.
But there are people that do
that, that raise the queens,
and when I buy these, if
I do, they come in a box.
>> Like that?
>> Jim Salander: Just like this
and you can get them in the mail,
and then there's one
of these little things
with the queen in it on the inside.
What other questions?
Quick questions, yes?
>> Do you make the bees that -
>> Jim Salander: Well,
I make the bees?
I get them, I buy them --
if I set my hive up right,
then the queen will be making
more bees, but if I wanted
to start one tomorrow, let's say
I have just the wooden stuff,
and I wanted to make a hive
right there, I'll make a hole
in the window and they can
come in and out of the window,
you don't think they'd
mind here, do you?
What I do is I can buy this,
and there's somebody else,
who takes bees from a hive, dumps
them in here, adds the queen
and sells it to me, and then
I dump them in my equipment
and if I've done my job right
the bees will like it there
and they'll stay there
and make honey.
And take care of the
flowers that are around here.
Yes?
>> Do you like your job?
>> Jim Salander: I do, I do,
and you know what the
best part of the job is?
The best part of the job --
no, the best part is
coming and talk to you guys.
Come in and talk to other schools,
other kids and teaching people
about bees so they don't have
to be afraid of them, OK?
But thank you, that
was a good question.
Yes? I'm sorry?
[Inaudible].
Yes, it's a hobby,
but you can learn how,
it's like a lot of other hobbies.
Yes?
[ Inaudible ]
>> How do they eat the honey?
>> Jim Salander: Oh, good question,
good question, good question.
In the winter when they
want to eat the honey,
they use that same tongue,
that they went to collect it,
but they don 't put it in that
special stomach, they just eat it
and they only eat a very, very
little bit, because it has
to be shared with all
the other hives --
all that hive, all the other
bees at the hive, it takes a lot
of cooperation, with
all of those bees,
so that they can do
all of these jobs.
They got to keep it clean in there.
Sometimes there's a little bit of
dirt, sometimes a bee dies in there,
sometimes there's a little chunk of
wax, they got to keep it real clean,
they got to keep it so it's just the
right temperature, it's not too hot,
it's not too cold, there's not too
much humidity, it doesn't get wet
in there, they got
a lot of work to do,
because it's all closed
up, and remember the dance?
It's dark in there, and they got
to do all their work in the dark.
Yes?
>> How do the queen
bees get the eggs out --
>> Jim Salander: OK, we can do this.
The bees, they make the queen, and
then the queen goes out of the hive
when she gets old enough, and she
gets strong enough, she goes out
and she finds a boy bee to be her
husband, and then she comes back
to the hive and she's ready to lay
eggs, but she never goes out again,
she never goes out again and
she stays in the hive for three
or four years, and lays thousands
of eggs, boy eggs, girl eggs,
all of that, that's all she does.
She doesn't make wax,
she doesn't sting
and she doesn't do anything
else, the other lady bees,
the other girl bees
do all that work, yes?
>> When she lays eggs,
where do the eggs come from?
>> Jim Salander: They come out from
her bottom; right out of her bottom,
just like a chicken,
a chicken lays an egg.
In the queen, she's got a
special apparatus for growing eggs
on the inside and a special
little opening to drop it out,
so she comes over to that opening,
she feels the size of it, she's,
"oh, this one gets a
little boy egg", kapunk,
and she gives it a
little boy egg, yes,
and the other one she
feels a little girl egg
and she gives It a little girl egg,
I don't know how she does that.
We have one more question,
one more question, yes.
>> What kind of bee
has the queen bee?
>> Jim Salander: What kind
of -- Well, what the --
the person who raises queen bees,
now with my hives they're set up so
that they make more
honey than they need, OK?
Some people set them up so that
they make more wax than they need,
some people like the pollen so they
collect the pollen from the bees,
but you can set it up, read the
books and learn how to do it,
so that you can basically
trick the bees
into making more queens
than they need.
Thank you all very much for
coming, I appreciate it,
now everybody gets a taste of honey.
Who's going to be doing this?
There's this, this stick
it in and get enough for --
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Please visit us at loc.gov.